[Music]
good evening I'm Reverend Denise Mason
I'm the pastor of Pleasant Valley United
Methodist Church and I'm so glad that
you were joining us here on this Good
Friday as together the table and
Pleasant Valley United Methodist Church
here in the service of solemn reflection
tonight we join with Christians around
the world who since the time of the
early church have gathered on this good
day a word that long-ago meant wholly to
remember our Lord's suffering and death
on a cross a cross that for our sake he
went to willingly now as we all know
this novel coronavirus pandemic it
prevents us from physically gathering
together but this evening thanks to the
wonders of technology as well as the
hard work of Gary miner and Ian Lavinia
we were able to gather in spirit from
many locations while I'm joined here in
the sanctuary safely staying six feet
apart from one another I'm joined by
Sandra Lavinia Taylor Hankey Pamela add
gate and Piper Vance and while we're
here
Brett Tilford the pastor of the table is
in his own home as our Mindy Runnels
Maggie Tilford and Roy Parker at
different times during the service the
screen will switch between us and
although we have the brightest and the
best people work
on this working behind the scenes to
help this all go smoothly well there may
be a few hiccups so I pray that you will
excuse those hiccups in advance a few
quick notes about the service itself
tonight we're going to be sharing in a
modified Tenebrae service a service of
deepening shadows which will include
scripture music and a few words from
both Brett and me the service begins
with a kir da a Curia is an ancient
liturgical Latin prayer which says here
da a lays on lord have mercy
Christe Eleison Christ have mercy the
carry a will be followed by the ringing
of the Bell thirty three times one time
for each year of Jesus's earthly life I
pray that you will use this time as well
as the musical interludes that will
occur after the Scriptures to reflect on
the meaning of this day what it meant
for Jesus what it meant for the
disciples and what it means for us
[Music]
[Applause]
well good evening everyone thank you so
much for joining us so one of the great
problems that's discussed at various
places in the Bible is the problem of
suffering and specifically the suffering
of those that the scriptures refers to
as the righteous you see righteousness
it's not perfection
it is not flawlessness but it describes
someone who wants to do good who wants
to live well in love God in and be
generous not only with their friends but
with the poor and the needy someone who
is seeking to orient their lives towards
love towards Christ but what happens
when that person suffers when someone
doing evil suffers then we can say well
it's divine justice that they they had
it coming but what about when the
righteous suffer for those familiar this
is one of the major themes of the book
of Job C job was a righteous man a good
man not perfect but good and yet he
suffers in fact not just him
but his entire family his wife his
children suffered tremendously and I
think anyone with a shred of feeling has
something that rises up in them and says
why why this should not be so why I've
had this sort of reaction often in the
last month as the new reports roll in
and I hear the stories of people
suffering there's the story of Nicole
Buchanan who tried to get her
husband conrad tested for the
coronavirus for weeks but they would not
test him because he was young he was in
his 30s he had no pre-existing
conditions and so the doctor said he
would be fine but he was not fine he was
terribly sick and he got sicker as time
went on he had labored breathing he was
suffering finally after two weeks it was
clear that that he wasn't doing well and
also his wife took him again to the
emergency room this time the doctors
were alarmed at his condition they knew
they had the virus positive test or not
and so they admitted him in the Cole
went with her daughter Skye to park the
car but when they came back they were
not allowed to reenter the hospital
because it was on lockdown and a few
hours later they were informed by the
doctors that there was nothing that
could be done in that Conrad had in fact
died and as a Nicole his wife was being
interviewed with tears in her eyes with
her daughter Skye beside her she told
the interviewer I never got to say
goodbye that's suffering and in fact the
book of Job ends with a few attempts at
some sort of an answer but they are
somewhat unsatisfying it's it's
basically something like well God is God
and you are not and that's true and I
agree that there is wisdom in
acknowledging that but the Bible doesn't
in there because then we come
to Jesus the one known as Emmanuel which
means God with us and mystery of all
mysteries at the end of his days he is
not whisked off to heaven and a chariot
of fire like the prophet Elijah and he
does not die peaceably in bed before
being resurrected instead he enters into
the very depths of fear abandonment
humiliation pain weeping suffering in
the cross it was as though in that
moment he was carrying in his very body
all of our rage our ocean of Tears our
fists shaking at the heavens our why me
why him why her why now as Isaiah
chapter 53 verse 4 speaking
prophetically says surely he has borne
our griefs and carried our sorrows
brothers and sisters if you follow the
crucified and resurrected one if you
worship and adore the God we'd come to
see in the face of Jesus in the crown of
thorns in his pierced hands in his feet
then you worship the God who understands
what it is to suffer and so tonight I
want to invite all of you watching to
listen closely to meditate upon the
story of the death of the Lord as we
proceed to read John chapter 18 John
chapter 19 in Psalm chapter 22
[Music]
after Jesus had spoken these words he
went out with the disciples across the
Kidron Valley to a place where there was
a garden which he and his disciples
entered now Judas who betrayed him also
knew the place because Jesus often that
Jesus often met there with his disciples
so Judas brought a detachment of
soldiers together with police from the
chief priests and the Pharisees and they
came there with lanterns and torches and
weapons then Jesus knowing all that was
to happen to him came forward and asked
them from whom are you looking they
answered Jesus of Nazareth jesus replied
I am he Judas who betrayed standing with
them when Jesus said to them they
stepped and felt the ground again he
asked them from whom are you looking and
they said Jesus of Nazareth jesus
answered I told you that I am he so if
you are looking for me let these men go
this was to fulfill the word that he had
spoken I did not lose a single one of
those whom you gave me then Simon Peter
who had a sore - drew it struck the high
priests slave and cut off his right ear
the slaves name was Malchus as commanded
Peter put your sword away shall I not
drink the father has given me then the
detachment of soldiers with its
commander and the Jewish official
arrested Jesus they bound him and
brought him first to Anna's who was the
father-in-law of Caiaphas the high
priest that year Caiaphas was the one
who had advanced the Jewish leaders that
would good if one man died for the
people Simon Peter and another disciple
were following Jesus because this
disciple was owned to the high priest
he went with Jesus into the high priests
courtyard but Peter had to wait outside
the door the other disciple who was
known to the high priest came back spoke
to the servant girl on duty there and
brought Peter in you aren't one of this
man's disciples too are you she asked
Peter he replied I am NOT
[Music]
[Applause]
then the high priest questioned Jesus
about his disciples and about his
teaching jesus answered I have spoken
openly to the world I've always taught
in synagogues and in the temple where
all the Jews come together I have said
nothing in secret why do you ask me ask
those who heard what I said to them they
know what I said when he had said this
when the police standing nearby struck
Jesus on the face saying is that how you
answered the high priest jesus answered
if I've spoken wrongly testify to the
wrong but if I spoken rightly why do you
strike me then Anna sent him bound to
Caiaphas the high priest now Simon Peter
was standing and warming himself and
they asked him you are not also one of
his disciples are you he denied it and
said I'm not one of the slaves of the
high priest a relative of the man whose
ear Peter had cut off asked did I not
see you in the garden with him again
Peter denied it and at that moment the
crowed
then they took Jesus from Caiaphas to
pilots headquarters it was early in the
morning they themselves did not enter
the headquarters so as to avoid ritual
defilement and to be able to eat the
Passover so Pilate went out to them and
said what accusation do you bring
against this man they answered if this
man were not a criminal we would not
have handed him over to you
Pilate said to them take him yourselves
and judge him according to your law the
Jews replied we are not permitted to put
anyone to death this was to fulfill what
Jesus had said when he indicated the
kind of death that he would die then
Pilate entered the headquarters again he
summoned Jesus and he asked him are you
the King of the Jews jesus answered do
you ask this on your own or did others
tell you that about me Pilate replied I
am NOT a Jew am I your own nation and
the chief priests have handed you over
to me what have you done
jesus answered my kingdom is not from
this world if my kingdom were from this
world my followers would be fighting to
keep me from being handed over to the
Jews but as it is my kingdom is not from
here
Pilate asked him so you are a king jesus
answered you say that I am a king
for this I was born and for this I came
into the world to testify to the truth
everyone who belongs to the truth
listens to my voice Pilate asked him
what is truth
he had said this he went out to the Jews
again and told them I find no case
against him but you have a custom that I
released someone for you at the Passover
do you want me to release for you the
King of the Jews
they shouted in reply not this man but
Barabbas
now Barabbas was abandoned
[Music]
then Pilate took Jesus and had him
flogged and the soldiers wove a crown of
thorns and put it on his head and they
dressed him in a purple robe they kept
coming up to him saying hail King of the
Jews and striking him on the face Pilate
went out again and said to them look I
am bringing him out to you to let you
know that I find no case against him so
Jesus came out wearing the crown of
thorns and a purple robe Pilate said to
them here is the man
when the chief priests and the police
saw him they shouted crucify him crucify
him
Pilate said to them take him yourselves
and crucify him I find no case against
him the Jews answered him we have a law
and according to that law he ought to
die because he has claimed to be the Son
of God
now when Pilate heard this he was more
afraid than ever he entered his
headquarters again and asked Jesus where
are you from but Jesus gave him no
answer Pilate therefore said to him do
you refuse to speak to me do you not
know that I have the power to release
you the power to crucify you jesus
answered him you would have no power
over me
unless it had been given to you from
above therefore the one who has handed
me over to you is guilty of a greater
sin from then on Pilate tried to release
him but the Jews cried out if he
released this man then you're no friend
of the Emperor everyone who claims to be
a king sets himself against the Emperor
when Pilate heard these words he brought
Jesus outside and sat on the judges
bench at a place called the stone
pavement or in Hebrew gabbatha now it
was the day of preparation for the
Passover and he was about noon he said
to the Jews
here is your king they cried out away
with him away with him crucify him
Pilate asked them shall I crucify your
king the chief priests answered we have
no king but the Emperor then he handed
him over to them to be crucified
so they took Jesus
carrying his own cross he went out to
the place of the skull which in Aramaic
is called Golgotha there they crucified
him and with him two others on one side
one on each side and Jesus in the middle
Pilate had a notice prepared and
fastened to the cross it read Jesus of
Nazareth King of the Jews many of the
Jews read the sign for the place where
Jesus was crucified was near the city
and the sign was written in Aramaic
Latin and Greek the chief priests of the
Jews protested to Pilate do not write
the king of the Jews but that this man
claimed to be the King of the Jews
Pilate answered what I have written I
have written when the soldiers crucified
Jesus they took his clothes dividing
them into four shares one for each of
them with the undergarment remaining
this garment was seamless woven in one
piece from top to bottom let's not tear
it they said to one another let's decide
by lot who will get it this happened
that the scripture might be fulfilled
this that's it they divided my clothes
among them and cast lots for my garment
so this is what the soldiers did near
the cross of Jesus stood his mother his
mother's sister Mary the wife of Clopas
and Mary Magdalene when Jesus saw his
mother there and the disciple whom he
loved standing nearby he said to her
woman here is your son and to the
disciple here is your mother
from that time on this disciple took her
into his home later knowing that
everything had now been finished and so
that and so that scripture would be
fulfilled
Jesus said I am thirsty a jar of wine
vinegar was there so they soaked a
sponge in it and put the sponge on a
stock of the hyssop plant
and lifted it to Jesus lips my God my
God why have you forsaken me why are you
so far from helping me from the words of
my groaning oh my god I cry by day but
you do not answer and by night but find
no rest yet you are wholly enthroned on
the praises of Israel in you our
ancestors trusted they trusted and you
delivered them to you they cried and
were saved in you they trusted and were
not put to shame but I am a worm and not
human scorned by others and despised by
the people all who see me mock at me
they make mouths at me they shake their
heads
commit your cause to the Lord let him
deliver let him rescue the one in whom
he delights yet it was you took me from
the womb you who kept me safe and my
mother's breast you on you I was cast
from my birth and since my mother bore
me you have been my god do not be far
from me for trouble is near and there is
no one to help many Bulls encircle me
strong Bulls of Bashan surround me they
open wide their mouths at me like
ravening and roaring lion i am poured
out like water and all my bones are out
of joint my heart is like wax it is
melted within my breast my mouth is
dried up like a potsherd
and my tongue sticks to my jaws you lay
me in the dust of death for dogs are all
around me a company of evildoers
encircle me my hands and my feet have
shriveled I can count all my bones and
they stare and gloat over me
they divide my clothes amongst
themselves and for my clothing they cast
lots but you Oh Lord do not be far away
oh my help come quickly to my aid
[Music]
[Applause]
when Jesus had received the wine he said
it is finished then he bowed his head
and gave up his spirit since it was the
day of preparation the Jews did not want
the bodies left on the cross during the
Sabbath especially because that Sabbath
was a day of great solemnity so they
asked Pilate to have the legs of the
crucified Men broken and the bodies
removed then the soldiers came and broke
the legs of the first and of the other
who had been crucified with him but when
they came to Jesus and saw that he was
already dead they did not break his legs
instead one of the soldiers pierced his
side with a spear and at once blood and
water came out he who saw this has
testified so that you also may believe
his testimony is true and he tells the
truth these things occurred so that the
scripture might be fulfilled none of his
bones shall be broken and again another
passage of scripture that says they will
look on the one who they have pierced
after these things Joseph of Arimathea
who was a disciple of Jesus though a
secret one because of his fear of the
Jews asked Pilate to let him take away
in the body of Jesus Pilate gave him
permission so he came and removed his
body
además who had first come to Jesus by
night also came bringing a mixture of
myrrh and aloes weighing about a hundred
pounds they took the body of Jesus and
wrapped it in the spices and linen
cloths according to the burial custom of
the Jews now there was a garden in the
place where he was crucified and in the
garden there was a new tomb in which no
one had ever been laid and so because it
was the Jewish day of preparation and
the tomb was nearby they laid Jesus
there
[Music]
yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
it is finished as those who loved Jesus
and followed him watch as they watch
while Jesus is nailed to a cross where
he hangs for hours and he suffers
horrendous pain until finally it is
finished they watch as the Messiah the
son of the Living God the one on soul on
whom so many hopes and dreams had been
placed
well the watch as he breathes his last
and dies and suddenly just like that
everything is over can you imagine what
that must have felt like can you imagine
what must have been going through their
minds as they watched their Savior
carried away to be laid in a tomb
carried away by none other than the
Pharisee Nicodemus the one who had
refused to be seen but with Jesus during
the day and only could come to him at
night as they watched they must have
been thinking what happened here I mean
if Jesus who was who he really said he
was well what went wrong I mean he's
dead and now what how are we to go on
they might have been think
maybe we made a big mistake here maybe
we put all our eggs into the wrong
basket as they stood there they must
have suddenly been overwhelmed
overwhelmed with a sense of complete and
utter hopelessness can you imagine that
day can you imagine a day where your
life is up ended a day where everything
you ever believed in was gone can you
imagine the feeling of looking into that
black abyss well we may not truly
understand how terrible that day was for
the disciples we all understand out
don't we and most of us have had times
in our lives where we have felt
hopelessness as we look at our world
today we as we face the devastation that
is being wrought by this virus the fact
is that many of us might be feeling that
right now I mean our circumstances might
be different but like the disciples we
to stand in kind of a no-man's land
don't we
we're anxious and we're hurting and or
frightened or frightened as we face an
unknown future and some of us are asking
the same questions that the disciples
asked what went wrong if God is a loving
God how did this happen and moreover how
do we go on from here if Friday was a
really bad day well Saturday must have
been beyond our worst nightmares because
Saturday you see all hope is gone
in his book who is this man John Ortberg
the author has some very interesting
insight on this and which begins with an
interesting question he says why is
there even a Saturday at all
I mean if Jesus is to die and be raised
again why wait
I mean why spread out the agony and wait
until the third day now you may have
noticed in reading your Bibles that
there's a recurring theme of what we
call third day stories now we don't have
time to delve into all those this
evening but suffice to say that all
these stories follow a basic pattern
they say the first day you see there is
trouble and on the third day there is
deliverance but on the second day
there's nothing on the second day
there's just more trouble on the second
day you see there seems to be no way out
at all and all hope seems to be gone and
although we plead and we pray on the
second day God seems at best silent and
at worst
God has abandoned us all together it's a
horrible horrible day the thing is you
see on that second day no one realizes
that they are in a third day story I
wonder how many of us as we read the
headlines and hear of the devastation
that this novel coronavirus is wreaking
throughout our world we're stuck stuck
in that second day stuck unaware that as
followers of the crucified one we are in
a third day story unaware that our faith
hinges on this fact and although it is
hard to fathom anything good on the
second day maybe in our anxiety and fear
we're missing the real miracle here
see we often think of Sunday Sunday the
third day is the greatest miracle but as
Ortberg says I believe Saturday is the
truly miraculous day see the miracle of
Sunday is that a dead man lived but the
miracle of Saturday is that in the
internal son of God lies dead and if we
can find Jesus in the grave if we can
find him in death where can we not find
Jesus where will he not turn up
[Music]
[Applause]
it causes me to tremble
[Music]
well thank you all for engaging in this
time of reflection with us and so let me
send you off with this benediction the
Jesus Christ who for our sake became
obedient unto death even death on a
cross he keep you and strengthen you
this night in forever go in peace
you